elle nicolas vidal bonjour merci nous
avons a rejoint sur l'antenne de rtl
france je le rappelle vous êtes
éditorialistes et directeur de putsch
médias alors est il utile pour vous ce
référendum sur le climat alors premières
observations quand j'ai reçu la
notification moi et j'ai vu emmanuel
macron référendum c'est sursauter je me
suis dit dans quel monde vit-on nous
venons de passer dans une autre époque
plus sérieusement le référendum pour
répondre à votre question olivier il ya
une chute hier sur la revente
aujourd'hui en france annie terre
économique sociale et démocratique
première question qui nous vient qui
nous pend lève c'est qu'est ce que ça
vient faire là ce référendum
alors pour entrer dans le vif du sujet
de ce référendum la protection de
l'environnement il faut le rap est un
elle est déjà dans le préambule de la
constitution la charte de
l'environnement rappelez-vous de 2004
lemaitre déjà l'un sert déjà dans ce
bloc de constitutionnalité
donc j'ai envie de dire avec quelques
uns quel humour que la balise verte est
déjà là finalement dans cette
constitution est une autre observation
qui me paraît intéressant c'est que
notre constituant les les faits pour
être intemporel
je disais martin allemand pour reprendre
les mots elle est faite pour résister au
temps et je crois que lui faire porter
un moment donné les émotions on va dire
du moment c'est pas souhaitable parce
que finalement quelque part ça
l'affaiblît pour pour aller plus loin
finalement emmanuel macron s'est
toujours présenté comme un homme
politique un chef d'état stark peur et
là il nous ressort un peu las de la
vieille politique emmanuel macron
pourquoi pour deux trois points
essentiels
c'est un référendum stratégique pour pas
se leurrer là dessus donc d'une part il
veut accrocher les écolos à la remorque
électorale pour 2022 et leur montrer à
faire un blanc-seing finalement de sa
volonté écologique de reprendre en main
le pays
il veut mettre aussi le sénat a tenu par
les républicains face à leurs
responsabilités vous savez suite à
l'article 89 pour la révision la
constitution ça doit passer devant
l'assemblée et devant le sénat et puis
une nouvelle fois il faut pas je le
disais un préambule emmanuel macron ya
une espèce de petite préférence
démocratique qui est là pour dire
regardez moi je fais des référendum
donc finalement et il faut faire parle
en disant que le référendum très
sincèrement il est hypothétique dans le
sens où il n'aura pas vraiment le temps
de le mettre en place
et puis aussi la france ne sauvera t
elle pas la planète à elle toute seule
ouais vous sembler reprocha émaillée de
macron de se soucier du climat c'est
pourtant une question importante
allée centrale la question sur le climat
mais alors il ya une grande incohérence
des manuels macron en vouloir faire en
voulant faire finalement une politique
néolibérale de traité de libre échange
en veux tu en voilà alors le ceta le
geste à singapour diatta le mercosur
avec d'autres pays parce que finalement
magali la politique néolibérale elle est
totalement antinomique avec une
politique écologique jolie jeune artiste
hier en revue de presse pour préparer
cet édito les supertankers vous savez
ces gros bateaux qui traverse la planète
en permanence pour aller à mener du port
et des denrées alimentaires çà et là
vous savez que ça représente 90% des
transitions de marchandises dans le
monde par la mer pas la mer et vert
exemple la mongolie aujourd'hui à des
pavillons de complaisance et là des
bateaux qui traverse finalement la
planète et il n'y a aucun droit qui
limitent finalement cette super
pollution d'ailleurs citez moi un port
une station balnéaire en mongolie où une
attache à la mer ça va être compliqué
donc finalement tout ça pour dire que si
les cohérences forte entre les traités
de libre échange et l'écologie
regardez le c'est en juillet 2019 les
écolos qui sont toujours très porté sur
ces questions le 23 juillet 2019
il ya eu le vote la ratification du
volet arbitrage à l'assemblée nationale
il y avait 32 d'agriculteurs et trois
journalistes devant ça donc il n'est une
cohérence forte entre une volonté
écologique que de parures de paraître et
les politiques néolibérales qui est
menée tambour battant en permanence il
ya un marche forcée allo nicolas
si ce référendum se tenait quel serait
le risque électoral pour emmanuel macron
emmanuel macron il ya le piège le grand
piège le trou béant de la notion
publicitaire finalement parce qu'une
grande majorité de français pourrait se
liguer dans ce référendum contre
emmanuel mâcon sans répondre à la
question
et ça c'est un risque énorme parce que
ce bloc l'a finalement des 60 % de gens
qui pourrait être contre la politique d'
emmanuel bach on pourrait se ressouder
parce qu'il n'y aura pas les divisions
les soustractions des divisions
politiques de la présidentielle vous
savez l'émiettement des parties marine
le pen dupont aignan et des ans et les
autres finalement ces gens pourraient
constituer un bloc extrêmement important
et voté contre emmanuel macron et je le
répète à la différence par exemple
rappelez-vous des référendum de
maastricht en 92 du traité
constitutionnel de 2005 de lisbonne donc
youri emmanuel macron il risque de
prendre une gifle électorale qui
pourrait effectivement la mienne ne pas
se représenter mais ça il l'avait déjà
dit chez nos confrères de brut
voilà mes maîtres pour entrer dans le
vif du sujet du moins pour essayer de
décrypter ça c'est quoi finalement cette
volonté de protection de l'environnement
donner un blanc seing aux écolos si la
fracture des deux france d'un côté vous
avez les écologies des politiques des
bobos mondialisée c'était classe
finalement un peu au dessus
qui ne voit que par l'écologie un avenir
commun à se dire qu'il nomination ni
frontières ils ne voient la société que
par l'écologie et de l'autre côté vous
avez bien entendu la france périphérique
vous le savez les jets les gens on en a
parlé mais il faut ensemble et j'ai des
gens qui eux et je le répète rappelez
vous la fronde des jeunes le début sa
portée sur quoi sa portée sur la taxe
diesel vous voyez bien que là il ya
vraiment une scission absolue entre deux
france gagne donc de frapper à plusieurs
de france mais cette c2 france là ces
élites bobo mondialisée ce que moi
j'aime bien mes chers parce qu'il paraît
rosen qui prennent des avions qui sont
adorateurs des couleurs et trois
poubelles vous savez et qui finalement
vont prendre des avions pour aller faire
le tour de la planète et qui finalement
ne voit dans l'écologie qu'un avenir
commun alors qu'ils n'ont pas eu un mot
pour la les ravages de la mondialisation
ils n'ont pas eu un mot pour les gilets
jaunes ils sont toujours prêts à signer
une pétition contre toute une série de
choses qui estime sur l'écologie 10
estime importante ça c'est voilà donc
c'est vraiment l'affrontement de ces
deux france de vision et qui sont
extrêmement on avis centrale aussi dans
ces questions de forme pour notre nation
vous savez que je suis très attaché aux
questions de la nation
et ça c'est une scission centrale merci
beaucoup nicolas vidal on abordera
évidemment si vous pouvez et si pour
être y avoir d'autres référendum à venir
mais ça ce sera l'objet d'une autre
intervention de votre part merci en tout
cas d'être intervenu ce matin en direct
sur rt france